to present the award for black-and-white
cinematography mr. Humphrey Bogart and
now for the black-and-white
cinematography the best achievement the
winner is in New York the winner is on
the waterfront
I'm very happy to get the award and I
want to thank the members of the crew
that helped me off without a picture and
Elia Kazan that trusted me and inspired
me thank
I must have an applause machine there
you know bogey I guess the two guys in
this town who ought to be most grateful
to the cameramen are you and me well
there Bob there is much they can do with
it with a face like mine but yours
presents vistas of opportunity
they must gaze on your face with all the
glee of a child contemplating his first
jigsaw puzzle I don't think either one
of us ought to go into it too deeply
who made you up Abbi
no this is one of the Westmore brothers
the one that ran away from home
now the phobia I want you to give me
just a little advice and I don't care if
this happens in front of the nation I
just want to know how can I get
nominated for an award well I'll tell
you Bob you first was the first thing
you've got to do is to stop playing
those those silly parts cut out all that
buffoonery you've got to go in put some
more serious roles yeah well I I've done
some very serious roles though I mean on
purpose
I wish I had his ball bearings to
present the award for color
cinematography Miss Patti
hirato
so they color cinematography the winner
three coins in the fountain
thanks very much to my crew
thank you and muchas gracias catty
you think that very good well yeah let
the speaker David would be a really good
Mexican accent oh yeah well I have to
that's where my tax man is hiding thanks
anyway sir welcome what's the third of
Mexico and now the award